thanks a lot and thanks for inviting me
so this is joint work with moses
cheryker and arvindan
so i'm sure all of you have heard a lot
of this since the morning but let me
just give a couple of minutes of
background about what we are doing here
so we have data from various sources so
you might have a bunch of documents some
speech data some sets of points in the
plane and so on and
the basic question you ask in learning
is is there a simple explanation for all
this data so in other words can you
think of all this data as coming from a
model with a small number of parameters
so that's the general question we want
to understand
and this has been very successful for
example
topic models for documents and hidden
marker models for speech and so on so
often they help you get a better
understanding of the data you have
okay
so i'm going to give an example of topic
model for documents partly because it's
listen it's one of the simplest models
and
in its simplest version
you think of a document as being about
precisely one topic and you think of a
topic as a distribution over words okay
so just to give an example you might
have a bunch of topics so say sports
wildlife and so on each topic is a
distribution over all the words in your
dictionary okay so like wildlife might
have some probability of seeing all
these ones
and the property here is that these
things add up to one
right so this is the simplest topic
model and here the parameters you have
are
the way firstly the weights for the
topics this is
given a random document what is the
probability that it's about topic i so i
will call that wi so the w sum up to 1
and for each topic i you have a
probability vector p i which is which is
the row of this
okay
and uh how can you generate a topic in
this topic model
so let's say you want to generate a
document with r words
then first you pick a topic with
probability proportional to these w's
so let's say you pick topic two
and
you pick r words independently according
to the probability distribution p2
so this is the model for generating
topics for generating documents
and the underlying assumption behind all
these methods is that
if you pick a random random document
from your set of documents that you have
and you randomly sample our words then
the output you see is roughly the same
as picking an r word document according
to this model
so that's when you say that this is a
good model for for the set of documents
yeah
and ah and the goal in all of this area
is uh generally assuming that there is a
good model for your data then how do you
find these
how do you find the parameters that is
the w's and the
probability vectors p
so what does this have to do with
tensors and as we saw in the previous
talks
uh the simplest way in which you see
tens are showing up is to ask yourself
the question so let's say i pick three
random words from a random document what
is the probability the first word is
some i second word is j and the third
word is k
and you will see that this is precisely
equal to
so
the calculation shows the probability
that
if you pick a topic r
so you do that with probability wr and
given that
probability of seeing word one word two
and word three is exactly the quantity
that i wrote
okay
and you can already see this has some
tensor feel to it so if you now form a
tensor whose ijk entry is precisely this
quantity
uh then you can write this out as uh sum
over r w r times p r out to product
product
and so this
illustrates why
finding parameters is essentially the
same as tensor decomposition
and this is generally the recipe for
tensor methods in mixture models
uh
and it's been used also
before the machine learning works it has
also been used in
the algebraic statistics literature
there are also older references than
these
and the general outline of these methods
is that first you estimate a tensor
whose decomposition somehow allows you
to read off the model parameters
and you do this estimation from the data
that you have
and once you have that once you have
that tensor you can then decompose the
tensor and then you can find the
decomposition
and this is found many applications so
so for example mixtures of gaussians
hidden markov models
recently wrong showed us about crabs
so
yeah so okay so all this sounds like a
nice coherent story so
so what
now be done now right so
there are actually two big caveats in
this
so first is the question of efficiency
so
generally in computer science the aim is
to find polynomial time algorithms for
decomposition
so let's say you are given this tensor t
which is
sum of outer products so i absorbed the
w into one of the p's
and the question is can you find
can you find these vectors p
and uh you want to do this efficiently
in time polynomial and all the in the
number of parameters involved
okay
and
another very important thing for in in
applications
is that our algorithm needs to be robust
okay so in the sense uh you need to be
able to work with a noisy tensor
what do i mean by that so
if you remember in this topic models we
estimated each entry of the tensor by
looking at a whole bunch of documents
right so if you take n samples of your
documents then typically you'll have a
one over square root n entry per entry
of the tensor
and
in practice we are only allowed a small
enough number of samples and so
dealing with error is important
so the goal in
so the goal for us computationally is
the following so we have a target
accuracy epsilon to which you want to
learn all the parameters
and let's say you can find this tensor
up to an error which is epsilon over
polynomial in it
so by taking the number of samples to be
reasonably large to be a fairly large
polynomial you can ensure that this
happens
and using this you want to infer the
parameters up to an error epsilon
usually you can try different r's so
yeah so for now i'll assume that i know
the r
so what is one case in which we can
solve both these problems so so that is
uh one of the main success stories that
we have it is the full rank case so
let's say you have a tensor whose
decomposition is pr out of product like
this and you you know this tensor up to
some error
now let's define the matrix p to be the
n times r matrix whose columns are these
vectors pr
and
so so the theorem here is that
if all the
columns of this matrix are linearly
independent in a strong sense that is
you have that the add singular value of
this matrix is at least one over a
polynomial in n
yes so
big p is a matrix whose columns are the
small p's piece
then you already know the small piece so
why
no no no so
we don't know what this thing is we just
know that there are there are some
parameters you estimated the tensor from
your documents
so you know this t but you don't know
what the ps are and that is the problem
but if you don't know
how you can estimate
p
no i'm saying you can estimate this t if
you don't know the
parameters p and what i will say is that
if the true piece happened to satisfy
this property
that sigma r is more than one over poly
then you can recover them
oh so sorry yeah so i just thought uh
sigma r is the r's smallest uh right
singular value
so it is uh so
unfold it to r by matrix and assume that
it has full rank and also there's the
lowest singular singular value is
reasonably big yeah so it's full rank in
a slightly strong sense
and it's drawn with sound so so it's not
unfolded
it's just a column so it's just uh so p
is this matrix which
is n times r
and its i column
is this vector pi
yeah i want what you want to find so i i
i see yeah
so the slightly cyclic thing here is
that uh
ah it's just
i see yeah it's a condition if the true
values happen to satisfy this condition
then
there is an algorithm to recover them
so you could be unfortunate and they
might not satisfy this condition
okay
so is the is that clear so
it says
again i'm just wondering so do you know
what the rank of the tensor is going to
be or do you assume that it is
so yeah in practice you usually try
different values but for now let's
assume we know what it is
and we know what it is and
we also know that if you build this
matrix
then
then this matrix has a good smallest
event
so um okay
sir so i'm just trying to so you
do you want to do exact decomposition do
you want to find some
tensor of small red that is close i
guess what is the
so in this case i want to find each of
the piece up to an accuracy parameter
i see and
the small rank tensor is near to your
target one
and
more importantly the decomposition
itself is also near to your target
decomposition so not just yeah
so the capital or is it smaller than
hand
yeah so in this case uh the figure is a
bit of is quite bad
otherwise
otherwise you will not have this
condition
right so that's why i call this the full
rank case where you have full column
rank
right right soon we'll move to these
so
yeah
so you know actually what you're talking
about something called the separation
rank in computational quantum chemistry
uh so the thing is given a fixed epsilon
you want to find the smallest r so that
t is uh within has an autumn
approximation
all right this is what you want do you
want or to be the smallest with it once
you fix absolutely
uh
no so those kind of conditions will come
to in a bit so that so are you talking
about the spark
no not that okay
what is the smallest r so that you have
a decomposition like this
that is the separation right but that is
not what you oh i see that's not what i
want so i want it for all the columns
so for for all the piece that you want
to find i i want this matrix p to be uh
so
to have columns that are full rank in a
strong sense
he wants to recover all the piece yeah
so this is ic
i see okay so you assume that he has a
decomposition like this yeah
so if t happened to have a decomposition
like this
then you can recover it efficiently
so actually that will be a general
flavor of all the results that i'm going
to say that if the decomposition p
satisfies certain explicitly stated
conditions
then i will be able to recover the
parameters
and uh this is true for all the results
uh that we know of about ten centicomb i
don't i don't understand so what
if we have
what's the difference between what
you're saying and and uh
like hack is saying so uh if you have
how do you know what is your target
uh
those two oh uh we don't so the target
decomposition is something that
is somehow given to us by nature or
something like this so we see the
document
right
well i guess the question if
the composition is unique then you can
talk about it
right
then you can think of trying to recover
it yeah i mean if the composition is not
unique then it would be difficult to
know
how to get closer
is this is correct
yeah i mean so in general you don't know
the decomposition beforehand the goal is
to find it so but you know the tensor
and you believe there is a decomposition
which satisfies some good properties
and then you want to find that
decomposition
approximately
with some small rank that's just
if there is a unique solution that would
also solve the problem yes
but it's a good point that even with
zero zero noise the prerequisite is that
the decomposition should be
right in some sense
yeah so if there is a unique
decomposition then if you
approximately like fixation
but without additional assumption that
the composition is unique
uh so that itself won't suffice so we
you will need this stronger assumption
on the decomposition
okay so
having stated all this i should say that
this is an old result so this has been
discovered many times and uh i think the
earliest earliest known thing is due to
harshman
so
so the result i stated here it's quite
strong so it says that
if you have r smaller than n and you
have this non-degeneracy property then
you can efficiently recover the
decomposition
but it
but it requires the strong
non-degeneracy property and the question
is can you hope to recover parameters
even under weaker conditions
and in particular if you have the number
of parameters you want required to be
more than n
the dimension then can you
can you still hope to recover the
parameter
and uh in this talk i will be concerned
with identifiability so which is uh
somewhat like uniqueness in something
and uh the the informal theorem here
which i'll prove is that
if the crisco if something called
kruskal's rank condition holds
then you can
you can i mean it is possible to recover
the decomposition up to any desired
accuracy epsilon
this will be the main result of the talk
and uh so the
so i
there's no known algorithm for this just
assuming the kruskal's rank condition
and uh that is like that is an
interesting open problem
okay
so the difference let me point out one
thing about the difference between this
about this result and the kind of things
we saw earlier in the workshop which is
about
uniqueness and under generic assumptions
so here firstly i have explicit
conditions on the decomposition such
that if it holds then you are able to
recover the tensor and secondly
so now i'm i'm
saying something about recovering a
tensor even if you know it up to a
certain small amount of noise
so that i think is the
difference in viewpoint
so first let me talk about kruskal's
rank conditions that i mentioned before
and uh
introduce what is called kriska's
theorem
okay and the general goal of
this theorem is to find conditions under
which the decomposition is unique
so and the conditions will involve these
matrices a b and c
these
vectors and so an interesting notion
that is that kruskal introduced it's uh
it also later has been introduced in
different communities it's what's called
what's now called the crystal rank
and uh for a matrix for an n times r
matrix its rank is the largest integer k
such that every k columns are linearly
independent
okay
so if you think of a
of a matrix like this so you want every
k columns to be linearly independent so
note that it is much stronger than the
usual notion of rank
which is essentially you want some some
k columns to be linearly independent
and it's also related to some notions
that are studied in compressed sensing
and kriskal's theorem says that if you
have a tensor
and
so from its decomposition let's say you
define these matrices a b and c as we
did before so
so you define a to be a matrix whose
columns are these ai's b to be a matrix
whose columns are the bis and so on
then
if the
if the ranks of these matrices satisfy
this inequality
so you have the sum of the kruskal ranks
to be smaller than twice the rank of
this 10 search the number of terms in
the decomposition plus 2.
then
this is the unique decomposition for the
tensor
so this was kriska's theorem
and
yeah
so
okay
all right and the goal of our result is
uh to get a noisy version of this okay
so let's say you you know a tensor only
up to a certain noise so can we say that
you can still recover something close to
the exact decomposition
so let's say you have a tensor t that is
as before but you have this noise term
and we want to find these a b and c up
to some small error
and
the notion that turns out to be useful
for us is what we call it's a natural
generalization of the kruskal rank so
there you require every k columns to be
linearly independent now you can ah
now you want every k columns
uh to be reasonably well conditioned
okay and the condition number is just
the ratio of the top to the bottom
singular values
so
so what this condition says is
if you take
any
k
columns
and if you restrict to this sub matrix
let me call it
so this is matrix a let's say
and this is some set of columns s
then if you look at this
ratio the sigma max of a restricted to s
divided by sigma min of a restricted to
s
then this quantity is at most tau okay
so this is called
the crystal rank with respect to this
parameter tau
and we'll be interested usually in the
case when tau is polynomial in n
there is nothing
because you're not about any finite
number
because
all of them are linearly independent
same as sigma minimum is
you know
it's as i mean it's just bounded
okay so so assuming this definition so
our theorem is roughly the following so
if you have a tensor up to a certain
amount of noise
then the decomposition is unique i will
get to what it means to be reversely
unique in a bit if you have this
property that this robust kruskal ranks
add up to at least two r plus two
so this is a natural analog of the
krska's theorem
okay and
so just to explain so what is it that we
are trying to do so let us say we have a
rank a tensor call it t and what we are
saying is that if you take
any other tensor that is rank k and is
close enough to t
then the decompositions of these two
tensors are roughly equal
so so in particular
if
if you give me any error parameter
epsilon there is an epsilon prime that
is polynomially related to epsilon
such that if t and t prime are epsilon
prime close to each other then the
decompositions are epsilon clause and
this is true up to a permutation so
there is a way of mapping the vectors of
one decomposition to the other
such that they are epsilon close
so this is the main gist of our theorem
and i'm going to state it formally in
which case looks a little more daunting
so so you have two two tensors t and t
prime both are rank k
and you know that they are epsilon prime
close to each other
and
the hypothesis is that the original
tensor t has a decomposition that
satisfies the kruskal's theorem a
kruskal's condition
so you have
k of a plus k of b plus kfc bigger and
2r plus 2
then if you take any other tensor that's
close to this tensor its decomposition
will be closed
so any questions about this
and uh so this is essentially a just a
way of saying what moses just pointed to
that
you can only hope to recover this
decomposition up to a permutation
because you can always permute the terms
of the ego
all right so some remarks before i move
on to how we prove this so firstly note
that
the conditions that we had in this
theorem are only about one of the
decompositions
so you had this decomposition of t
and all our conditions are only about
this decomposition and you don't really
need anything about this a prime b prime
and c prime you need something mild but
that's a technical point
and an interesting implication for
example for this is that if you take
some tensor t whose decomposition is
good and that it satisfies these crystal
conditions
then any other tensor that is close to t
cannot have a rank that is smaller than
r because
in some sense if you are close enough to
t then you must have a decomposition
that's close to the decomposition of
this and therefore it cannot have a
smaller
and another thing which i will not state
is that this also generalizes to higher
order tensors so and this is in the same
way that there's a result of dylatha
that
that's an extension of kruskal's theorem
so
the theorem the robust version also
generalizes in the exact same way
and before getting to the proof
i just wanted to know that the main
difficulty is handling this uh handling
a one over poly end noise
so remember we had these epsilon and
epsilon prime in the theorem
and ah so if we are epsilon prime close
we want the decompositions to be epsilon
close
and the goal is to somehow relate these
two by only a polynomial factor and that
turns out to be the difficult part and
somehow if you naturally follow
kruskal's proof you get an exponential
bond so you have to do something more to
get to a polynomial
why do you care about polynomials
so
yeah and the general reason we care
about this is that
we can obtain tensors only up to a one
over polynomial accuracy
and that's why
and to get that accuracy you need
polynomially many samples
and so that's why we care about handling
one over poly and noise
because usually you assume your running
time and the number of samples you have
is only polynomial
okay
all right so let me give a brief
overview of the proof and
and will assume some simplifying
assumptions that you you have these n
cross r matrices a b and c which are in
the decomposition
and
i will assume that their ranks are
exactly equal to n
what that means is that if you take any
n columns so now you have a matrix
that's n cross r and r i'm thinking of
as something slightly bigger than n
and i'm assuming that any n columns of
these are linearly independent in a
strong way okay so they have a
reasonably big condition number at least
one over a polynomial in it
and
the
two there are two main steps in the
proof and the first one is uh is
essentially showing that uh
so first you show by you show that a
prime is a scaled permutation of a b
prime is a scaled permutation of b and
so on then you show that the
permutations are all equal
so you'll see this in a bit
and it turns out that the crux of the
proof is the first part which is
essentially showing that a and a prime
are permutations of each other b and b
prime
all right
so recall that
so our hypothesis
just to write it down
is
we have tensor t which is
which has a decomposition
i'll just write it as a
b c
so
this just means
denser t prime this is this has a
decomposition a prime
and we know that t minus t prime is
small
from this from these conditions we want
to say that a is a permutation of a
prime b is a permutation of b prime
okay
so
so let's just to illustrate the proof
let me first make a simplifying
assumption so i'll let's assume that uh
you that no two columns of a prime are
parallel okay turns out you don't need
to assume this you can actually show
this but uh let's assume
and uh
so the crux of uh kriskal's proof is in
show is in
considering
the spaces spanned by a subset of
columns of these matrices okay so so you
have two matrices a and a prime and you
want to show that their columns are
permutations of each other
and the goal is to do this by looking at
spans of subsets of the column
so let's define the span of asa best as
exactly the span of the columns indexed
by this set as
and
roughly speaking the main claim of
kryskal's proof is the following so you
you look at sets of size n minus 1 so
you look at n minus 1 different indices
and the claim is that if you look at the
span
of the columns in a prime of these
indices
so this is a span of a bunch of columns
of a prime then it contains at least n
minus 1 columns of a
so just to draw a picture you have a
like this and a prime is
you look at a bunch of columns of a
prime
and you look at their span and it
contains at least n minus one columns of
a okay so this will be the
claim
and uh
the result will be that if this is true
then uh you can also get this theorem
for smaller s's
so assuming you can show this claim for
for sets s of size n minus 1 then you
can also show this for every s
and note that if you can show this claim
for s for s's of size 1
then what this means is that for every
column of a prime you have some column
in a that is parallel to it
and this is the claim roughly that we
wanted to
so this is a general outline of the
proof and
all right so let me first show that this
base case holds which is that if you
take a set of size n minus 1
and then if you look at n minus 1
columns of a prime then
the space spanned by them contains at
least n minus 1 columns of a
so this is the base case and uh so we
have these a and a prime and we are
looking at n minus one columns of a
prime
so note that uh we know that
uh t and t prime are very close to each
other so if you looked at the
decomposition so you know that
so the left side is t and the right side
is t prime and we know they are both
very close to each other
so what does this mean so if you look at
any vector w
and you take the inner product of this
tensor in the leftmost component with w
then you get exactly this term so the
left-hand side inner product with w is
precisely this so you have inner product
of this vector w with a r
and you have b r auto products here
so we know that if these two tensors are
roughly equal then the dot products with
any w are also equal
so you have an equality of this form
and this is a this is where the trick
comes in so let's say you pick w to be
orthogonal to all the columns
in s
so recall that s was a set of size n
minus 1 and we are living in n's n
dimensions so there's always some column
that's orthogonal to all the columns in
in s
so if you if you picked such a w
then
what happens to the right side so the
right side has inner products of w with
these ars as the coefficients
so all
so all of these n minus 1 coefficients
that correspond to s would vanish
so the number of terms that you have on
the right side is at most n over 3 plus
1.
the plus 1 is because the n minus 1 of
them were 0 and they were a total of
four and over three terms
and
so the key observation that kruskal made
is that
so this rank condition essentially
implies that the same must be true on
the left hand side okay so the rank
condition is you should think of it as
saying that somehow these b's and c's
are in general position in some sense
and then if you had a sum of more than n
over 3 terms
and they added up to a rank n over 3
matrix
somehow you get a contradiction because
you have
more than n over 3 terms which are
somehow in general position adding up to
a rank smaller than n over three matrix
so this is the idea of uh this is the
key idea in crisco's proof
and so what does this mean so this means
that
for this w you must have at most n over
three terms on the left side
which are non-zero whose coefficients
are nonzero
and this means that
there are at least n minus one columns
ar that
are also orthogonal to w and being
orthogonal to w essentially means you
are in the space spanned by the
by the as
so so this is the
gist of the proof for this for the case
s being n minus one
and uh
so we want to show this for every s and
in particular if we can show this for s
equals 1 we would be done so the natural
thing is to do some kind of a downward
induction so you start
now with let's look at the case when s
is n minus 2 and see what it happens
okay so let's start with some s of size
n minus two
and uh idea is to use induction so let's
define
s sub i to be
a set obtained by adding one new index
to s
so so you have some set of size n minus
two and you add one new index and uh
there and roughly n over three such
choices because you have n minus two
things and you have a total of four n
over three columns
okay
and uh so so by the inductive hypothesis
what you know is that for each si
there is a set of at least n minus 1
columns of a that lie in the span of
this a prime sub s i
so this was the
inductive hypothesis so let's call this
set of columns t i
so these are exactly the columns of a
that lie in the span of this
a prime sub s i
and somehow the idea of this
and the key observation about these sets
ti
is that if you look at two different i
and j
that is you take some set s first
expanded to i then you add j to it
so
if you have any column in the set ti
intersection tj
then that column must also be contained
in the span of just a sub should
better to just explain what is roughly
going on so so we are trying to use this
inductive hypothesis and what we know is
that
if you have if you take subsets of
columns of a prime then for subsets of
size n minus 1 you have enough columns
in a that are that lie in those spaces
now we are taking two different subsets
of
of columns of a prime obtained by
looking at s and adding i and obtained
by s and adding j
and for each of these you have some
columns
in a that are contained in those spaces
and what we are saying that is that any
column in this intersection must
actually be
in the span of this a sub s
and
so this turns out to if you write it out
you can easily show this i showed that
this must be true
and uh
but the
key observation is the following so if
you have
so let's say you denote by t
uh the set of columns that are contained
in this
that are in the span of a prime sub s
so this is the set that you want to show
is reasonably big so for the inductive
claim
so
so what we what we showed here is that
if you took any two different i and js
then columns in the intersection of
these two
ah must all lie in t
and this is what is called the sunflower
family in combinatorics so you have a
bunch of sets ti's
such that the intersection of any two of
them is precisely equal to the set t
okay so you should think of these ti's
as the union of the score plus one of
the petals
so all of them contain the core and
each of them has a disjoint pedal
and using the fact that each set
has size at least n minus one
the goal is to show by accounting
argument that you that the core must
have size at least n minus two
and uh this turns out to be quite simple
to prove so let me not go into this for
the sake of time
and it is it's a simple counting
argument that shows that you must have
enough columns that are in the quadrant
this completes
okay
and uh
now let me just uh
mention why
showing that
showing a robust version of this is
tricky
so recall that
so we had we were looking at these
spaces spanned by subsets of columns
and we were proceeding by some kind of a
downward induction so first we said for
all sets of size n minus one you have
enough columns in a that are also there
and eventually we want to get down to
sets of size one
now the problem with this inductive kind
of an approach is that uh
so if you just try to mimic this proof
what you obtain is that if you have the
claim for
sets of size n minus 1 with an error
parameter epsilon
then you can prove this for n minus 2
with an error of only epsilon times n
so what exactly do i mean by the error
so we want uh
so now our permutation lemma is a robust
form of this
where
first set
where we still look at the spans
of subsets of columns of a prime
but we want these columns to not exactly
lie in that space but we are but
approximately line that way
and
that's where the error parameter epsilon
comes in
and it turns out that
if you just try to follow the previous
proof you'll lose a factor of roughly n
in each step
and this is an inductive proof where we
want to go down n steps so you end up
getting
an exponential dependence on the
exponentially large
uh
increase in epsilon exponential or
factorial
yeah you actually get n to the n so it's
more than even worse yeah
yeah
so
so this is why you can't uh simply mimic
this proof and uh
so that's why so what this means is that
unless you started with an extremely
good solution you cannot uh you cannot
just to apply this technique
and but it turns out that we can still
use the same outline so
instead of basically following this
proof you can argue in a more
combinatorial way i won't go into the
details
but you essentially
need a stronger sunflower argument
and using this you can actually fix and
show that you can
you can prove this theorem with only a
polynomial
uh loss in the epsilon
so i won't go into the details because
they are rather technical and probably
not very illuminating
okay so with this
let me conclude the proof of this of the
robust lemma
and
i'll point out some general open
directions and things which i feel are
interesting especially to
i mean to this workshop
so the first question is of course uh
are there polynomial time algorithms
just assuming kriska's condition
okay not assuming something like full
rank as i mentioned earlier in the talk
so
so that would be a very interesting
very interesting contribution
okay
and uh there's also this question that
sham talked about and i guess wrong
alluded to where
can we use suppose we are actually
interested in these mixture model type
problems
then can we use tensor based algorithms
in the case when r is bigger than n
so here it turns out a lot can be done
you'll hear more about this in the next
talk
there are also more recent works
assuming what's called the incoherence
okay
and what i feel is
is a nice direction is if we can use
the generic results that are known in
algebraic geometry and show robust
versions of them so in some sense you
take it
so what we know is that up to ranks
roughly n squared over four we know that
an n times n times n tensor has a unique
decomposition can you actually show that
this decomposition is stable in some
sense so in the sense that i spoke of
before
so you
you take two tensors of
rank
let's say n squared over four that are
very close to each other then should
their decompositions be close
so this i think would be a really
interesting problem to solve but i mean
you probably won't not just should they
be close but some estimate of how close
right right and the goal is to be
polynomially
is to be polynomially close in the sense
if your error is
you know say if your tensors are say 1
over n to the 10 apart
then you want let's say the
decompositions to be 1 over n squared
apart
okay starters do we even know such a
result of their exponential equals no we
don't yeah that would be the starting
point i guess
yeah any i i don't think there's any
notion of a
noisy version of these
algebraic results that are known and
that i think would be a very interesting
thing at least in terms of applications
all right so let me end here
okay we have time for a few questions
i guess everybody's hungry
at the beginning you mentioned
so it's actually arvind and will mention
that probably in more detail in the next
talk but it's basically a generalized
eigenvalue problem type algorithm
so you have two matrices that have the
same a common diagonalization
and it turns out you can retrieve it so
the idea is to look at different slices
of a tensor
and
so they turn out to have a common
diagonalization
and this you can find efficiently
so that is roughly the idea of that
another question
all right let's thank you again
let me break